what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are with dr. Steven Kane right now
thank you for joining us we are gonna be
talking about planetary habitability
which is very exciting and there's a lot
to unpack around this topic we are still
at I pack at NASA right now and during
the the XO Cal week this EXO Cal
conference is going on that's really
important and there's so much to talk
about regarding astrobiology and how
life has evolved on other planets and
how we're finding it that out so we'll
dig into that in this conversation
steven has PhD in astrophysics from the
University of Tasmania in Australia and
then he is now with the astrobiology
initiative within NASA's NASA
Astrobiology Institute and that is you
got about a team of 10 people that are
working on planetary habitability
imaging missions and your backgrounds
great let's let's let's run through this
so this is exciting stuff you okay so we
initially when I was looking over what
you were working on
I saw gravitational microlensing and
then you you you taught me about how
like imagine back in 1995 when we were
like this is what we're gonna be using
to study it and then like 10 years later
we figured out that like transit
photometry was like wow was
significantly more advanced and finding
habitability so even just that
realization for me was just so profound
but you know now having spent a couple
decades in this industry like tell us
about I guess that process and about
like you know how you feel about that
and like where you're at now tell us
about that well it was an exciting time
when I joined this whole process back in
1995 because the the field was really
exploding at that time 95 was when there
was the announcement of a planet around
51 pegasi and it was a fascinating
discovery because it was a giant planet
in a four day or but none of us really
understood it
but it also caused people to project
forward about well what can we do here
what's the path forward and NASA had
many roadmaps that they planned at the
time a large part of that was a radial
velocities which was the method that was
used to find 51 peg but also
gravitational microlensing which was
seen as a way in which we could get to
the really small planets and so radial
velocities micro lensing with those two
in tandem was seen as as two of the the
key parts going forward and so I first
got involved by by studying
gravitational microlensing as a graduate
student and you were you were teaching
me about this and give us a bit on the
radial velocity as well but with
gravitational microlensing when you see
this two stars that just better line
with your path of sight that you see
some of that light from the back star
get a little bit brighter and then you
can see if potentially there is a planet
as well in between it and then that
light would slowly dip as it increases
and then increase again and you could
yeah right yeah
that's right and gravitational
microlensing was a theoretical proposal
dating back to 1936 when Einstein had
written a paper about this as a favor to
a friend now when I say is a favor to a
friend that's because Einstein didn't
believe that this was an observable
effect he thought it would only ever
remain theoretical but it was based on
his 1915 general relativity theories
because it involved the way in which
mass affects light and space-time and
things like that as we entered into the
90s and the use of sensitive detectors
on telescopes became more more prominent
we realized that wait a minute I think
we can do this because the new detectors
were allowing us to observe thousands of
stars simultaneously and by doing that
you're able to see these relatively low
probability events which Einstein had
had predicted and the brightening of
these stars caused by Michael lensing
because it's so sensitive to mass it can
in fact detect plan
masse objects and so in in the mid-90s
the picture was is that there was this
realization that we could do this it was
still very much a theoretical study it
had been observed for for some stars
there hadn't been any planets found but
this was one of the pathways forward as
to actually discovering planets and
that's like a big moment for
civilization to be like wow we can we
figured out how to do this and it's like
a really hard way to do it and then we
figured out a much easier way to do it
which is still hard but then we figured
out the transit photometry so you had
guess what how did that transition go
for you well it was actually quite a
natural transition into other methods
because the gravitational microlensing
method is very very difficult you only
get one shot at this because these two
stars lining up happens very rarely so
if you're able to scan a star for a
planet and you see something in the data
you can't go back to that star and
verify it or go to other your colleagues
and say can you check this for me it's
is it's one shot and so that makes it
very very hard yeah so the probability
of those stars lining up again is about
once every million years so with the
tree right normally we want to go back
and keep sampling a planet as it's
orbiting the star and we just couldn't
do that with micro lighting but but
Michael Anton did start to discover
planets and at this point has found
about 30 to 40 planets but it's very
much a statistical technique because we
can't do the follow-up observations but
from there I started to look into the
transit method which became popular
around about 2000 because one of the
known radial velocity planets we
observed it and saw that a it transit
its host star and we realized oh wait we
can do this and we can set up cameras on
the ground that monitor thousands of
stars at a time
and hopefully see something and so I was
building these instruments and
developing ways in which to process the
data which were actually quite similar
to the ways in which I processed the
microlensing data which vote because
both of them are looking at variations
in brightness of many stars at once so a
similar similar technique that
translated very well to transits okay so
okay now that we've shifted to the
transit photometry you know your work
then had been shifted in that direction
so you're continuing to make assisting
with the Kepler telescope and that
mission and then Tess yeah so so I was
building ground-based facilities which
were detecting planets you know we're
talking about two thousand three four
five and we started to find more and
more planets using the transit method
and we realized this was a viable
technique and this was all leading up to
2009 when when Kepler was going to be
launched and Kepler was essentially
solving this issue of of beating down
the low probability of a particular
planet trends in a star by just what I
call a brute force approach let's just
observe hundreds of thousands of stars
at once and we'll see something and you
can calculate what you would see because
we can there's a simple geometry that
results in the probability that a planet
will transit and so Kepler was launched
in 2009 wildly successful but it was
only observing at a particular patch of
the sky and also Kepler was only ever
intended to be a statistical mission it
was never intended really to be a
mission in which we would follow up on a
particular system because we knew in
advance that the stars were quite faint
and that would be difficult to follow up
on them so that's where test comes in
because test not only looks at most of
the sky but it's looking at very very
bright stars and this gives us
opportunity to do the kind of individual
system follow-up that we couldn't do
with kept lub for most of the time okay
so that is very exciting I think what is
as exciting as you know Kepler and test
go up and do that it's kind of like
you're behind the scenes analysis of
what's going on with the catalog of all
these exoplanet candidates and
especially the interest of the habitable
zone planets so yeah so let's start
unpacking this okay well so the the
habitable zone is a is a difficult topic
to talk about because it's a very
misleading topic and that the Hubble
zone is is somewhat of a misnomer
because it implies the zone in which
things are habitable and because of that
very obvious confusion of the of the
term which by the way it doesn't just
confuse the public it confuses the
majority of the scientific population
and a it's a real problem in the name
people have proposed changing the name
nothing else has ever stuck but the the
reason that that we use it is because
it's it's a phrase which was born many
decades ago back in the 1950s and 60s
where people started thinking about well
where could we find liquid water where
could look water remain in liquid state
around the star and in the 1990s people
started to use computers to calculate
climate models which would quantify what
this range was for the earth and these
were simple what we call one-dimensional
climate models they they as by
one-dimensional I mean they considered
just simply a column of air from from
the ground up to space and just look at
the dynamics of that that that was the
first attempt at really trying to just
state okay this is what we can say about
what the extent of the hobble zone is
which means what how close to the Sun
would he need to move the earth before
it starts to evaporate its liquid water
oceans how far away would he need to
move it and before it freezes over
but the concept as a whole because it's
based on the earth is is really meant to
be a first guess
and that means that it's a concept which
we primarily will be using in the years
ahead
for target selection which planets
should we look at first because we'll
have many many more targets particularly
with the discoveries of tests then we
will have follow-up resources to be able
to look at so we knew we'll need to make
some very tough decisions but the for
that reason the the criticism of well
the Hamill's own doesn't tell you
whether that planet is habitable and
that's that's absolutely true but that's
not what it's intended to do it's
intended to point us in the right
direction to hopefully lead us to what
we know worked at least once which is
the earth of course and then carry on
from there so okay you you you're very I
like how your so you know realistic
about things I was telling you about
this earlier just that there's so much
hype in so many of these industries and
so for someone to be like you know hey
let's slow down let's actually think
about how we're thinking about things
and so in this case with the habitable
zone it's it's it's almost as though we
we've we thought we've forgotten that
life evolves potentially and even other
places in our own solar system and
places that are not the habitable zone
like whatever's going on between Mars is
crust and it's in its core and
whatever's going on in Titans oceans and
in Enceladus and Europe and cetera so so
and Venus you actually specifically
mentioned Venus a lot in what you've
work on as well as what we were talking
about that if the Sun gets brighter over
time that the Venus could have
potentially been habitable and lost
habitability that and yeah keep
unpacking this yeah there's a this of
course a lot of things that we don't
know about habitability we only have the
single data point which is the earth and
there's there's a lot of objects within
our own solar system that we know very
little about we we don't know if there's
life under the ice of Europa many
suspect that there
is myself included but we don't know and
the truth of the matter is that we're
probably going to have to go there and
drill through the ice and do some kind
of sample return mission to answer that
question now if that's what we have to
do in our own solar system what hope do
we have for a planet that's around
another star and yeah it's a the the
thing to always remember about astronomy
in general of course is a remote sensing
science intrinsically so we're
extracting whatever information we can
from what light we receive and it's it's
incredible what we can do but we also
have to understand the limitation to
that and so when it comes to planets
around other stars we will never have
Institute data for for these planets
only Institute data we will ever have is
for the planets within our solar system
and so what we need to do which is the
common scientific approach which is to
gather what data you can and then create
a model which you then apply to other
systems based on the data you're able to
extract for those but the the
habitability within our own solar system
is something that we still very much
struggle to understand like you said the
the Sun has become brighter with time
which means that the radiation
environment of the earth is not the same
as it was a billion years ago two
billion years ago
and the same is true for Mars and Venus
so there are ideas that the Venus could
have started with very similar
conditions to the earth they could have
had liquid water oceans and and as the
Sun became brighter conditions change on
Venus
it lost its liquid water oceans the
water vapor moves to the to the
atmosphere and water vapor is a very
efficient greenhouse gas the surface
warms up on the earth the the earth has
a place to store its carbon which is the
carbon silicate cycle where the carbon
is is is precipitated down onto the
surface and moves into silicates in the
rocks which is subducting into the
interior and then outgassed again we
call that the carbon cycle carbon
silicate cycle that's how the Earth is
able to store its carbon Venus with
now liquid water oceans had nowhere to
store its carbon except the atmosphere
so that's where it all went and so
that's why we see the carbon dioxide
dominated atmosphere and leanness now
but that that was a process that took
place we don't fully understand how and
it's quite possible that many of the
planets that we find within the
so-called habitable zone of other stars
are actually runaway greenhouses like
like Venus said that they could well be
but like I was saying that the Hubble
zone is not the zone in which things to
have all at best it could tell you that
if there is water present then it could
be in a liquid state that is the very
best that it could tell you it certainly
doesn't tell you whether it's it's
habitable we've heard some people say
that well water equals life because
wherever we find water we find life on
the earth but the thing to remember
about the earth of course is that the
earth has been contaminated contaminated
by life for four billion years is bad
this stage it's burrowed into the deeps
deep into the Earth's crust wherever we
find anything on earth we find life
which is why we spend so much time
decontaminating rovers we sent to Mars
so that they don't carry anything with
them so water doesn't necessarily equal
life and so we have to be very careful
about this term the the Hubble's own
that and understand that it is a very
first guess in a science when we have to
hold up our hands and say we are in our
infancy we do not understand this topic
but we are willing to explore and learn
and and just take it from there yeah and
I think we're gonna end up potentially
returning to this subject as we go
throughout this conversation because we
were teaching you about this to is just
this there's not really a really strong
conversation going on a really strong
relationship between planetary science
here in our solar system and
exoplanetary science and you're
explaining to this in
most relatable terms this is all remote
sensing this is not sensing here sensing
here is when you send to go drill into
Europa otherwise you're just taking
light that's reflecting off the
atmosphere or through the atmosphere off
of the planet from their host star and
that's traveling light-years and
light-years and we're just getting the
faintest of signals and it's so much
more you know difficult yeah yeah there
is still a substantial distance that
exists between XO planetary science and
planetary science and and one of the
reasons that that isn't obvious is
because in your mind you can remove the
XO from XO planetary science and
convince yourself that XO planetary
sciences is is pretty similar to
planetary science but nothing could be
further from the truth because XO
planetary science you have to understand
that are most of the methods that we use
to find planets particularly the
terrestrial ones and certainly this is
true of kepler and Tess it's what we
call indirect methods which means we're
not measuring the planet we are
measuring the star we are measuring the
effect the planet has on the star we are
and from there we are inferring the
existence of the planet and the
properties of it but we are
fundamentally measuring the star and the
history of this is such that the people
who are in this field are stellar
astronomers they are people who
understand stars very well and they're
using the techniques that have been used
to study stars for over a century and
these are just been brought to bear on
this new regime where the object
orbiting is is comparatively small and
the the problem there is that as we have
become more and more sensitive to
smaller objects we've hit this regime
particularly once Kepler started
producing data we hit this regime where
we were finding objects which were no
longer giant planets like Jupiter there
are terrestrial objects and we don't
understand them and the planetary
science community looks in in in wonder
at the science which is coming from EXO
EXO planetary science but at the same
time they wring their hands at what they
see is trying to do
when it comes to for example
understanding habitability because the
planetary science community understands
that for a lot of the things that we're
trying to do with exoplanets we can't
even do for objects in our own solar
system so if I was to discover an object
which was the mass of the earth and the
radius of the earth which is almost
identical to to Venus Venus is 90
percent of the mass of the earth and 95
percent of the radius within our
uncertainties of our measurements we
couldn't tell the difference between
Venus and Earth and then what we try to
do is model an atmosphere for it well
look at Venus we understand very little
with only sent a few Landers back in the
60s and 70s those were the Russian
Venera spacecraft which only lasted an
hour on the surface before they melted
and so we understand very little about
the surface the lower atmosphere of
Venus when we try to run climate models
on Venus they catastrophic ly fail most
of the time we we have great difficulty
in modeling the atmosphere of the of the
planet that is the same size and mass as
the earth and right next door and yet we
try to do this for planets around other
stars this is this is the challenge and
it's going to require a deeper
collaboration between the EXO planetary
science community and the planetary
science community share that expertise
and and hopefully find a path for
forward where we are able to construct
this model that I mentioned construct a
model from Institute data that we can
really effectively apply to planets
around all the stars that's the real key
forward to understanding habitability as
a whole yes so we need to learn the kind
of astrobiological models of our own
solar system and how it has evolved
across all these different planets to
better understand or give us some sort
of a better footprint as to where as to
when we have so much less data and so
much more noise and so much less signal
how can we make sense of that with most
efficacy yeah
so another thing to remember about that
is that if you're just looking at it at
a planet if you could imagine the state
of our knowledge of objects within our
solar system if we had never left the
earth and by that I don't mean man
missions I mean if we had never let sent
probes to Jupiter or Saturn to the outer
solar system if we'd never sent Landers
to to Mars or Venus or sent any
spacecraft and we were purely basing it
on what we could see through the
telescope how limited our knowledge
would be the the the issue in XO
planetary science is that it's like that
except probably about a million times
worse you know because at least we can
resolve these objects but it's important
to remember that as a civilization even
as as little as about 80 years ago the
the people believed honestly that there
was a civilization on Mars it was just
taken as fact and for Venus particularly
because we couldn't see below the cloud
cover there are movies from the 40s and
50s and so on that portray a
civilization living on Venus it it
really does require a great deal of
actually going there and measuring to
understand these objects otherwise we
could be greatly misleading ourselves
with an incorrect model I really look
forward to better imaging and
understanding literally the planets next
door especially Venus I'm happy that you
brought Venus into such
perspective so okay on your website H Z
Gallerie comm HC Gallery org links in
the bio by the way check it out HC
gallery org you can go and see a lot of
all of the different habitable zone
planets and you have a counter on there
it's will 125 or so is that about what
it is 125 so tell us about what you've
seen in your categorization of the house
zone discoveries we've had so far as
much signal as you can find from the
data yeah so I calculate habitable zones
the extent of the hubble zone for all of
the stars around which planets are
detected and then I create catalogues of
these III published a catalogue of these
for the Kepler mission a couple of years
ago but as you mentioned I have this
website which is meant to be all
exhaustive for not just kept all planets
but all kinds of planets which are in
the handle tone and as I mentioned
earlier this is not intended to be a
catalog of habitable planets because we
don't know but it is intended to be a
list that will provide guidance as to
which of these would be most useful to
do follow-up observations on thirst if
what we're interested in is finding the
shortest path to potential buyer
signatures evidence of biological
activity on the surface that interacts
with with the atmosphere and so it's
it's difficult for using results from
transit missions like Kepler and Tess in
terms of filling out that space of
finding planets in the Hubble tone
because those methods are more sensitive
to planets which are closer to their
stars and so what that means is that and
this brings Venus back into the
spotlight again which is that we are
more likely discovering a whole range of
Venus analogs first and many of them
which is exciting are on its own if
you're interested in Venus but even if
you're interested in habitability
sometimes people wonder well what is
what relevance does Venus have to have
the ability because if you think of
habitability some scale we have earth at
one and then Venus would undoubtedly be
at the other but Venus could have been
habitable at some point and that's
something which is actually taken into
account in calculating the boundaries of
the of the Haverhill zone there's
there's additional boundaries called the
optomistic boundaries of the hubble zone
which extend it slightly further under
the assumption that Venus could have had
liquid water on its surface up until
some late stage in its history
as the Sun got brighter so we have
limited numbers at the moment like you
mentioned there's about 120 or so
planets in the catalog which are known
to be planets in the habitable zone but
it's really yes yes and I should say by
the way that the the catalog does not
discriminate on size of the planet you
can certainly you can you can categorize
that within the the catalog yourself if
you're on the interest in terrestrial
planets but it also shows you giant
planets which are in the Hubble zone
because it's an interesting thought
experiment to ask well what would the
Galilean moons system be like if they
were at its orbit
you know and in so giant planets and
potentially habitable exomoons that sort
of thing is also taken into account in
that catalog yeah this this reminds me a
lot of our conversation that we were
having earlier about the crunching all
of these variables because you know what
would it look like if the if we had like
a 28 moon system or around Earth or what
it would look like if the star was a
little bit dimmer or the star was a
little bit brighter um all these
different what if statements are
basically what exists in other solar
systems and it's just up to us to go and
discover it and find it and or run the
simulations here and try and figure it
out but I really like that aspect of
calculating variables and seeing how
things evolve and just having a better
desire for our own understanding of
astrobiology in our own solar system
yeah there are it's true that there are
many variables and it's another thing
that we need to be mindful of when we're
considering the differences between what
we learn about exoplanets what we learn
about the objects within our own solar
system the transit method tells us the
size of a planet that's how step one if
you like when we're learning about the
properties of a planet from something
like test discoveries then we follow it
up with a different method typically the
radial velocity method we measure the
mass what we learn beyond that it then
it's
to become very very difficult once the
James Webb Space Telescope is launched
we will course follow up the planets
which are in the Hubble zone and see if
we can measure the atmosphere but even
then there are many things that we
haven't measured we have not measured
the rotation period of the planet we
haven't measured the obliquity the tilt
of the axis like through the earth
that's 23 knife degrees which gives us
our seasons we we won't have measured
that at the point when we get these
atmospheric observations and if it's
tightly locked or not that's something
that we we try to calculate from a
theoretical point of view but but that
is difficult because it depends on a lot
of intrinsic properties of the planet as
to how long it takes to become tarley
locked so there are a lot of properties
of the planet which is still out of our
reach and and the question is those
properties that we can't yet measure
things like the rotation period do they
have a strong effect on what the surface
conditions might be like which is what
we ultimately care about and the answer
is yes they have a huge effect yeah yeah
and and so there's still a still a long
ways to go it won't be until we can
directly image planets that we actually
start to unlock all of the first-order
properties that really drive the climate
and so that's gonna take a little while
longer yeah I just I love the idea of
imaging our own solar system first and
like yeah well at least simultaneously
we need more funding and all these
projects in order to be able to do so
simultaneously okay so this has been a
really thought-provoking conversation a
very realistically you know grounded
conversation about where our attention
should be you know very realistic sense
and a calm sense and not necessarily
living in a super hyper excited sense so
I really appreciate that a lot okay so
how about we talk a bit about what's
going on with the next generation of of
evolution on the planet regarding space
we're sending your test is up now James
Webb's coming up
for that the space economy is going on
somewhere someone some Japanese
billionaire is orbiting the moon next
and we have all these small sad
companies where do you really think
about the space economy in the future
and what that means for for us moving
forward I think any interest in space is
good the the the issue when it becomes
commercialized is that well we're not
wanting to sound obvious but but it
becomes commercialized in other words it
becomes about what is the profit margin
of this enterprise I have spoken to many
many many of my colleagues about why did
you first become interested in astronomy
why did you decide to pursue it as a
professional career and never once did
any of them say oh because I hoped that
a byproduct of my research would lead to
the next generation of velcro or
something like that never once has
always been because they have an
intrinsic interest in the science and we
see that as something our value to
society I think I think it's imperative
to society that we have this intrinsic
interest in the universe that goes
beyond commercial exploitation of of
that science which is sometimes what
what is referred to as the spin offs
argument is if it wasn't for this space
enterprise then we wouldn't have this
medical device or something like that
but that's not why anybody doesn't and
we should be real about that and we
should also be real about that the fact
that that this is this is something
which encapsulates the the imagination
of many young people to get interested
in stem in various science projects and
and pushes the boundaries of this
forward and and removing that kind of
enterprise is kind of similar to
removing of the club arts and music and
things like that the things that make us
human so I so that that's the downside
of it in in the sense that I
I would like to see more interest in all
avenues but let us never lose sight of
why we're doing this in the first place
and why we're really interested in this
that's really important what you just
said they're just who gets into
astronomy because of the big bucks you
know
people people get into this rally
because they fall in love with it and
that they want to bring this to the
world and of its straight importance to
inspiring us to understand our oneness
and how we best progress moving forward
sustainably okay a couple of these like
last sort of questions as we as we come
to an end
do you think we are alone in the cosmos
that's something I've thought about a
lot and about the the Fermi paradox and
the explanations for it and when you
look at the history of life on Earth and
how quickly life evolved and and and the
fact that life did seem to start pretty
soon after the had a in period when
earth was cooling off and you look at
the frequency of terrestrial planets out
there you look at the history of
evolution on the earth sometimes we can
tend to think of humanity as being some
kind of apex of the pyramid of evolution
that it all leads to us evolution
doesn't necessarily favor the ability to
build a spaceship it favors reproduction
and adoption to environment you know we
would all still be speaking dinosaurs if
there was not the KT event at the end of
the Mesozoic for example you know and
say and so from this I in in considering
how long it took for a complex life to
evolve on on the earth my feeling is
that organic like basic kind of life is
actually pretty common that that basic
life
single cell that sort of thing is a
natural consequence of a planet having
liquid water on the surface for a long
periods of time that that would allow to
have a have a stable climate I think
intelligent life is is quite rare
my feeling is yeah and and one of the
one of the issues in all of this is of
course we can't help but be anthropic
about it and and we bring that to the
table whenever we think about well how
would we recognize intelligent life some
people say we don't know what we're
looking for but we'll know it when we
see it I'm I'm a little more skeptical
about even that I feel like we won't
know it when we see it or maybe only
five percent of the time and because we
make enormous assumptions about how they
would communicate the the the second
star about contact of famously proposes
the prime numbers maybe some universal
language but who knows it's that that's
not necessarily given at all it's so
difficult to separate ourselves from our
worldview that I think it's almost
impossible to predict how that
communication would happen and therefore
if we would recognize it at all so so my
prediction is that intelligent life is
extremely rare that the physics required
to travel the large distances may
unfortunately not exist and and and that
may be a huge stumbling block there
could be a number of reasons earlier -
I'm glad you said it again that that
just maybe we just may explore our own
solar system and then just enjoy our
solar system maybe try and get a Proxima
Centauri and you know because they'll
still take us hopefully 20 years to
travel four light years or you know
whatever so this is tough stuff the
physics are not in our favor and and so
maybe civilizations turn inward when
they achieved the singularity maybe
that's part of the equation
what do you think is if we're in a
simulation or not it's I've had a lot of
people give talks about this about the
this whole concept about whether we
could be in the simulation and I find
them really interesting in a
philosophical and intellectual sense
that it's it's kind of one of these cool
black Moorish things to to explore if we
never know the answer to that it won't
bother me at all because if this is a
simulation it's an awesome one I'm
loving it
good job to the Creator you know so I I
don't know if it's something that will
we'll ever be able to fully answer and
in fact I'd be awfully disappointed if
somebody created some philosophical
argument that went through a bunch of
logical steps and concluded that we are
not you know ergo we are not in a
simulation that would be terribly
disappointed because even just having it
out there is a tantalizing possibility I
find as I said philosophically
intellectually it's kind of fun worlds
that we get to design and go live in and
so could already be living in one of
those for 80 years right now right right
okay let's ask you okay just two more
questions second last question is how
should we maximize human potential wow
that's a tough one it's this the answer
to this question and this is related to
something that we were also talking
about earlier it appears to be time
dependent many people of of our vintage
NOLA have seen society changed
significantly over the last couple of
years with with the internet and social
media and the ways in which people are
using their time and it's it's um it's
something where at the risk of sounding
like
as somebody who's who's not nearly as
older czar this makes me sound but
related to attention span you know the
ability to focus on tasks because and
the reason I say that is because that is
I think a fundamental part of becoming
absolutely drawn into and fascinated by
a subject if your interest can only be
held for a short period of time and it's
just extraordinary to to me how hard it
can sometimes be to get people
interested about not just astronomy but
but general life sciences Earth Sciences
Space Sciences as something that wow I
can't believe that we're actually doing
that as a civilization that's incredible
and I want to learn more about that
instead you have to fight against you
know Pokemon go and various things like
that but it's it it's something which
creates an extra challenge to science
education and III believe it's a
solvable problem there of course I I
don't want to be too general in the way
I'm talking about this because there are
still vast waves of people who are
coming into science we see this in
exoplanetary science because it's
growing so rapidly and that couldn't
happen without huge amounts of interest
so it it's it's something that we just
need to adapt to the way in which
information is passed on in process and
hopefully that will what will helping
increase our potential enough the
announcement to your question but I but
I do hope that as a civilization we
continue to recognize our small place in
this universe and respond proportionally
to that realization in trying to
understand it that's the key yeah that
last part is so good and so is what you
said earlier we are it's a paradox we
are both nothing a grain of Sam but
we're also everything we're Devine and
it's beautiful but also the notion of
focus focus is so
with the birth of this last couple of
generations especially the one that you
know I grew up in the one that's growing
up right now the smartphone babies and
stuff like that this is this is going
insane if we're not able to be very
careful with manipulation propaganda
deep fake psychometric all the cyber
stuff we're now generating generation
and manipulated and that are just not
focused on the important things that we
need education prosperity actualizing
their own souls into the world all this
type of stuff so I'm glad you brought
that up as a huge pillar of it okay see
you in last question what's the most
beautiful thing in the world
my my ounces this is gonna sound
slightly cliched but I will say that I
think the most beautiful thing in in the
world is the world is the universe I I
fell in love with the universe when I
was very young I grew up in outback
Australia outback Australia and I had a
trampoline in my backyard when I was a
kid at night I would go and lie on that
trampoline and just look at the Stars
fell in love with it then it's been my
mistress ever since it's the gift that
keeps on giving and it's something that
makes me unable to relate to folks who
create conspiracy theories or you know
like I have feel they have to add a
layer onto reality because if reality
isn't enough for you then you're not
looking hard enough in in my opinion I
think that the the universe is just this
fascinating thing that that we could
spend eternity trying to understand and
really really enjoy I love that
beautiful answer and I hope we can give
as many children as possible that sort
of laying on the trampoline in the
middle
the Outback and looking up because that
definitely does a great deal of
inspiration and you go door f---ing for
adults how we get out there and get that
ego Dorf what a pleasure this has been
talking about habitability about
exoplanets about it's the actual science
of local astrobiology within our solar
system this really difficult signal that
we're getting from far away this makes
it very difficult but it's very
realistically grounding and I really
appreciate that a lot even thank you so
much for joining us on the show and
talking to us really appreciate it
everyone if you had a good time
definitely give us a comment below let
us know your thoughts we'd love for you
to join the conversation also don't just
consume go and create go and make cool
things with this go make art make music
make shows make books make businesses go
and create with this content also check
out HZ gallery org the links in the bio
definitely go check out the habitable
zone gallery that stephen put together
and thanks everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it much love